people of the internet it's been another
week and another bit of news for
hogwarts legacy fans this week it comes
to us in the form of a tweet shared by
the official avalanche wb twitter
account just to be clear this is 100
official and was also shared by
community manager chandler wood as well
now there were two big things shown off
in this footage one clothing for our
character and also what appears to be
goblin armor then they gave us a few
more hints by showing several different
variations of the character creator and
boy let me tell you the level of detail
in this guys is incredible now one of
the first things i did was grab
screenshots of each one of these
different shots and shared on my twitter
page here the quality isn't that great i
think because just twitter compression
when they share videos isn't all that
great so you do lose out on some of that
detail but it at least gives you a quick
snapshot view of each item now i will
tell you guys straight up i am not a
clothing expert so very likely that i
will get the technical name on some of
this wrong but i think what we have here
in this first one is a waistcoat and
then a jacket on the outside here also
has what appears to be either a floral
or maybe some sort of star pattern here
but the most striking thing about this
one to me is this little emblem here in
the top left of the screen i guess it
would be on the top right of the jacket
here but it appears to be some sort of
symbol it looks to me like an o with
maybe a wand through it and i mean the
only thing i can think of is it bears a
striking resemblance to some of the
logos that we have seen for ollivanders
over the years in fact if you take a
look at the wizarding world of harry
potter right here in orlando it looks
very very close to this logo right here
now clothing at ollivanders i don't
believe that is something that is canon
or something that we've ever seen before
so i don't think we should just
immediately take this as fact and say oh
they got these clothes from ollivanders
instead i think we should be asking
ourselves hey what that potential logo
and or pendant is and then also why it's
there now i'm gonna have to go back
through the trailer and see if there's
any time when we can see this on the
main character as well but you guys may
already know if you do let me know in
the comments below and we may perhaps
talk about it in another video if we
move on to the next one here this bit of
clothing appears to be inspired by
mexican cultures and the thing that
jumped out to me quickly on this one is
if you look closely at this waistcoat
here and i think what you see here is a
couple of different skull designs in
this pattern here you see one here one
here one here one here and then just a
couple more smaller ones kind of
scattered throughout there's also the
pendant here right at the top in the
very center and i know this thing has a
technical name but it is just escaping
me right now i cannot think of the
actual name of it oh wait is it a bolo
tie i think it's a bolo tie and then we
have the shirt with the high collar here
and this looks to me like a silk
material again guys i am totally out of
my element when it comes to clothing i
could be totally wrong on all this but i
think the most striking thing about both
of these here is just the level of
detail here that we have seen in both
these so far and trust me that's going
to be a theme throughout all of these
moving on to the next one here and now
we have two different sets of goblin
armor one of these has the hands and
wrist area completely covered you see
the one on the right here also has a
hood this one to me looks more like
maybe like a magic type goblin a mage of
some sort whereas i could see the one
with the full helm and kind of the
shoulder pads over here being a more
battle type mage and i know we see both
of these in the trailer i'm almost
positive we see them in the gameplay
trailer and this is just a much closer
look at that in terms of any pendants or
designs that we see here we have the
belt buckle in the very center which
seems to be some sort of spiral pattern
again i'm almost positive that we see
that in the trailer somewhere and then
also at the top of the hood we have this
other little design pattern as well so i
don't know if these mean anything if
they're connected to anything specific
or it's more of just the pattern they're
using for the goblin designs in the game
and then the next one is an up close
look at both the gauntlets and the
shoulder pad area they're just showing
the level of detail that is going into
this armor guys now i got to be
completely honest i always expected
hogwarts legacy to be a good game to be
an engaging game to be a game that would
police the fans but i don't know that i
fully expected the level of graphical
fidelity that we're seeing here because
everything we have seen so far just
looks fantastic i know in the trailers
we had those characters in the
background who their faces kind of
didn't look quite right yet but seeing
the level of detail of things like this
right here gives me more confidence that
they're going to have all that ironed
out by the time of the game's release
now i don't know that every single
character we come across is going to
have level of detail like this but the
fact that this right here i mean this is
on all the goblin armor in the game you
would assume that to me is a great sign
from there we move into shots that show
off the character creation process and
there's just so much to say about these
guys i mean the level of detail again i
just keep coming to that word detail i'm
just gonna let these scroll through here
for a bit and i want you to take a look
at the variations in the skin tone on
all these different characters then take
a look at the little imperfections that
we see in the skin you see little
freckles you see moles you see blemishes
the different eyebrows and all the hair
options they just look so good and so
incredibly realistic by the way i can't
tell you how disappointed i was when i
realized that because these characters
are 15 there's probably very little
chance of us having beards in this game
so i guess when i make my character in
hogwarts legacy i'm gonna have to make
them a younger version of me with more
hair on top of the head less hair on the
face now after seeing all this you could
be wondering well how does this actually
look in game well they actually just
confirmed that robe physics are
officially in the game they weren't
removed and i break that down in the
video on the right side of your screen
now if you're new here and you want to
stay up to date on all the hogwarts
legacy news theories and discussion then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
before you go as always thank you all so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon